You can imagine the flood
and then you can set yourself straight
and then you can prepare for it and that
means maybe you can stave it off,
but it also means that maybe even if you
don't stave it off,
you could ride it out and that's
actually the story of Noah because what
happens with Noah is that he can see
that things are not good and that
there's a flood coming and God is maybe
letting him know and it says in the
story that Noah walked with God,
remembering that's what Adam did before
he got all self conscious about the
whole thing.
He walked with God.
We'll talk about that more next time,
but what that would mean maybe is
because Noah was straight and he put
himself together and his familial
relationships were good because it also
says that it his antenna were working
and he could see a little farther into
the future than someone whose vision was
completely obscured by,
by fog and chaos.
And he could tell that things were not
going to go well.
And so he prepared for it.
And because he prepared for it.
Well then things are actually went
pretty well for Noah even though the
flood came and so that's an interesting
thing because that's an.
That's an indeterminant issue in human
existence.
How big a hurricane would it take to
wipe out New Orleans if everyone was
heard?
Well,
the,
you're not going to wipe out the Dutch.
I mean that's going to be a tough one,
man.
You're going to have to conjure up a
pretty damn big storm to take out their
dykes.
Oh,
how thoroughly defendant New Orleans be
if nobody in the municipal municipal and
state governments was corrupt.
Well,
end of the hurricane problem because
that's something that we could clearly
deal with.
We know how to do it and the same
applies in your own life is that there
are floods come and you can bloody well
be sure of that.
That's absolutely 100 percent certain.
Some of them are going to be personal,
some of them are going to be familiar.
Some of them are going to be social and
political and economic.
It's like,
are they going to be catastrophes for
you or are you going to ride them out?
Are you going to prepare or the first
issue might be,
well,
do you have your act together well
enough to see them coming
with enough advance warning so that you
can take proper measures maybe just to
sidestep it,
maybe just don't go where the flood is
going to be.
That's a simple thing,
but maybe you don't have that luxury.
Right,
and so it is going to be a catastrophe.
Maybe someone in your family is going to
get really,
really sick,
right,
and maybe maybe there's just a tiny
pathway through that that everything
doesn't fall apart.
It doesn't end in divorce.
It doesn't end in death.
It doesn't end in sorrow,
doesn't end in catastrophe,
but the margin of errors like slimmed
down to virtually zero and every
imperfection that you bring to that
situation is going to increase the
probability that that tragedy is going
to turn it into something
indistinguishable from hell.
And that's coming.
It's coming your way.
Absolutely,
and so then you might think,
well,
since it's coming your way,
maybe the best thing to do is to put
yourself together so that when it comes,
it can be the least amount of awful
possible,
so I'll close with this story.
This was a very affecting story for me.
My mother in law had frontal temporal
dementia and she developed it quite
young.
She was about 55,
something like that,
and her husband who is very extroverted,
man about town guy,
I grew up in a small town.
Everybody knew him.
He was charismatic,
drank too much charismatic,
good businessmen.
Quite a remarkable person,
a real character,
but not exactly a family man.
Even though he,
he,
he provided for his family very well,
but when his wife got sick,
he really took care of her man.
It was something to see because that's
no joke.
Dealing with someone who has Alzheimer's
for all intents and purposes,
because they get taken away from you
piece by piece and that is not pretty,
and then it's also hard,
right?
Not only is it catastrophic,
but it's hard,
and Jesus,
he just stepped into that like perfectly
and it was way less awful than it could
have been way.
It was just a tragedy.
It wasn't hell,
and then I was there when she died and
my wife's family are actually pretty
good at dealing with death.
As it turns out.
My wife's sister is a palliative care
nurse and you have to be pretty tough
cookie to be a palliative care nurse,
but you can do it,
which is pretty interesting because that
means that you can go make relationships
with people at the last stages of their
life that are genuine relationships and
people just die on you nonstop.
And yet,
you know she's a competent,
alive,
alert,
fun person.
It's like two thumbs up for her man that
someone you can rely on in a tragedy and
her other sister is a pharmacist and my
wife has volunteered in palliative care
wards and is also very good at taking
care of people who are genuinely not in
good health.
And so we were there when my mother in
law died and course you can imagine.
Here's a,
here's a deathbed situation for you.
Your mother in law is dying and
everyone's at each other's throats,
so like you think that's uncommon.
Then your eyes aren't open because it's
plenty bloody comment and then it's not
just a tragedy.
It's hell.
And like maybe you can stand the tragedy
but you can't stand the hell.
And in this situation that isn't what
happened is everybody pulled together
and what happened was while she died,
but what was so interesting was the
family actually came together more
tightly as a consequences.
So although there was something taken
away,
on the one hand,
there was something gained on the other
that wasn't trivial and I'm not trying
to be optimistic and you know,
isn't the universe a wonderful place
about all this?
Like someone died in an ugly way and it
was harsh,
but God,
it was a hell of a lot better than it
could have been and maybe it was good
enough.
That's the thing you know,
is that this is something that I
constantly wonder is that if people did
what they could to speak the truth and
pay attention,
then maybe the tragedy that's part of
life wouldn't have to deteriorate into
the unbearable hell that doesn't have to
be part of life and maybe we could
actually tolerate the tragedy or maybe
we could even rise above it and maybe we
could even mitigate it,
you know,
because we can.
We do that sort of thing all the time
and so it's always an open question.
When the Eliana and put it very well,
are the floods the consequence of the
fact that things fall apart or are the
floods of consequence of the fact that
people make mistakes that they know they
shouldn't make and make anyways they
sin?
Right?
And that's to miss the mark,
right?
Because that's an archery term to send
in.
That means maybe they don't even specify
the damn target,
which is really,
you're not going to hit it unless you
specified or having specified it.
They just say,
Oh,
to hell with it.
It's not that important.
It's like you gotta be careful when you
say something like to hell with it.
It's not that important because one of
the things that might happen to you if
you say to hell with it,
it's not that important is that you
might actually end up in hell for a
pretty prolonged period of time or maybe
for the remainder of your miserable
existence because it's certainly the
case that people do exist there and I've
seen them exists there and once you're
there,
it's no trick.
It's no simple matter to get the hell
out and so it might matter that the
things that matter get addressed.
It might matter that you do what you can
to walk with God.
Like I said,
we'll talk more about that next time and
it might be that that is how you build
an ark in are protected from the flood
even if the damn thing comes.
And the thing is it will,
and this is a funny thing too,
that I've noticed about our education
system and the way we teach students and
their trigger warnings and all of that
absolute rubbish.
I think in most of my lectures I'd have
to have a trigger warning every 15
seconds.
So as I tell my students when they're
young,
it's like,
look,
don't fool yourself.
You know you're going to develop a
serious illness,
at least one,
maybe two or three,
and one of them is likely to be chronic
and if it isn't you,
it's going to be someone you love.
It's going to be your husband,
it's going to be your parent,
it's going to be your kids that's coming
and so as a lot of death and pain and so
like just exactly what sort of person
are you going to be when that shows up
and that's the right question.
It isn't how are you going to be happy
in your life?
It's like,
good luck with that.
It's a stupid ambition anyways,
as far as I'm concerned because it's too
shallow,
you know,
happiness.
You're lucky that comes,
uh,
comes and goes,
like the sun coming out from behind the
cloud.
If you're happy,
man,
more power to you,
enjoy it,
enjoy it.
It's a,
it's a gift from the cosmos to be happy,
but at pursuit.
No,
no.
The pursuit is when the dam flood comes,
you want to be the person who built arc
and that's what the story of Noah is
about and the thing is the flood is
always coming.
That's another thing that's worth
commenting on with regards to this story
is you know there's an apocalyptic
element to the Judeo Christian
tradition.
There's an idea that the end of the
world is always at hand and that you
should prepare to be judged.
And the thing about that is it's true
and the reason that's true is because
the end of your world is at hand and it
will certainly come and when it comes,
you will be judged because it will be up
to you to figure out what to do with the
fact that your world just collapsed.
And that'll be a moral problem of
ultimate severity because it'll push you
right to your limits and you'll find out
exactly where your unaddressed
weaknesses lie because that's what
happens in a crisis.
And so the reason that that's an
archetypal reality and it lurks
underneath the entire Judaeo Christian
structure,
the apocalypse,
the impending apocalypse,
is because we always live in apocalyptic
times and your world is always in small
ways and large ways coming to an end.
And so what do you do?
You prepare for it,
you prepare for your world to come to an
end,
and then maybe when the end comes,
you get another world.
That'd be a good deal.